the number one thing that I thank my
parents for is not putting me in a fake
environment you got your prospective
happy happy
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you uh thank you so
happy to be here first and foremost I
want to wish my sister Liz a happy
birthday it is her birthday so let's
clap it up for her I got to speak up my
mom's birthday and my sister's birthday
this year so it's pretty cool
um so look I'm super excited to be here
I've been dying to come to your
wonderful country I appreciate the warm
welcome and I've spent a lot of time
thinking about this conversation this
keynote this event and more importantly
why you're here what value can I bring
to you what's happening in the moment
you know my story is a very simple story
in my mind I stand here today for a
couple of core reasons patience at the
forefront of being a practitioner self
awareness there's there's a lot that
goes into this moment for me and and
most of all it's understanding the
moment that we live in and for me the
thing that excites me so much this
afternoon is we're living in a
remarkable moment where this device has
fundamentally changed the outcome of all
of our lives whether you understand it
or not and I think what is most
interesting is have you depending on
what you're trying to achieve in your
life have you started harnessing the
capabilities of this device there are so
many different people here with
unlimited different circumstances but
one thing I know across this entire room
and I'm very flattered by the turnout
across this entire room the one thing we
are all connected by in our ambitions is
that before you can achieve your
ambition you need the attention of other
human beings to achieve it if you do not
have the attention
of the end consumer when you are trying
to raise money for your startup when you
are trying to sell your product when you
are trying to change people's minds
bring awareness to a cause that you are
passionate about when you are trying to
achieve something the starting point is
attention and the attention of the
consumer has shifted to this device the
platforms on this device the Facebook's
and the Twitter's and the instagrams and
the youtubes and LinkedIn's and the
googles of the world dominate our lives
in a way that I think we're starting to
understand I think all of us agree that
over the last two three four years
whether it's because of politics or your
buying behavior we're starting to all
understand that this is a little bit
bigger I know that as somebody who's
been standing on stages like this for 10
years talking about the power of
Facebook and Twitter that in 2009
whether it was the Arab Spring or other
things that happen in world there was a
little bit of understanding wait a
minute this is big big but I think today
as we stand here in 2018 and heading to
the next decade I think people are
starting to understand this isn't
becoming big this is the big thing and
everything is secondary I would argue
that we are probably at the point now
where life is actually being lived
through here and this is now secondary
and I understand that a lot of people
may not like that and that feels weird
and I get it the problem is technology
doesn't care about how we feel it just
happens
our grandparents our great grandparents
our great grandparents they thought a
plane was weird they thought a car was
weird they thought a television was
weird technology is moving very quickly
and attention is shifting very quickly
and there's only two things that matter
to me in this talk today and there's
only two things that I'm gonna try to
achieve here which is can I get your
operating system
in the right direction in two places one
the most important operating system
which is this right it makes me upset
that you spend more time trying to fix
your technology than fixing your brain
right and number two your operating
system on this this and this this and
this do you even understand you know to
me this is an interesting conference why
are you even here you know to me the
most interesting question is why are you
here well I appreciate that thank you
but why right like I appreciate there's
a million different reasons but if
you're here just because you've been
following along and you wanted to see me
or things that nature I appreciate it
but why are you even following me in the
first place where are you going and more
importantly why are you driven by
economics are you driven by legacy are
you driven by the fact that you you know
one of the things as an immigrant from
the Soviet Union growing up on the east
coast of America one of the things that
I spend a lot of you know one of the
things that gravitate me so heavily to
the Asian market in general and I'm
being general right here with the Asian
market but there's two things I'm
unbelievably passionate about number one
just the hustle grit right I am
absolutely in net score blown away by
the DNA of Asian entrepreneurs in
general it just has more grit than other
parts of the world and I appreciate that
I gravitate towards that the other thing
I'm very fascinated by is parenting and
I am unbelievably passionate about the
fact that I know pretty much no matter
what your age is here I'm looking at
everybody pretty much across the board
in this entire room I have a lot of
different point of views on how you were
parented than the way your parents
parented you I think one of the most
interesting things about this part of
the world is the pedestal that parents
put on the past
which I believe is the modern education
system what you should be doing with
yourself and all the pressures that so
many of us deal with to try to make our
parents happy in the cliche doctor
lawyer good school way in a world where
everything's changed that might have
been very nice for 1997 and 1984 and
1976 there's a problem the whole game of
life because of technology has changed
we still live in a global education
world where most kids are taught to
memorize [ __ ] when everything is on your
phone we are living through a very
important time and so for me the thing
that I want to get through is do you
understand why you're doing it and are
you capable of doing it and not worrying
about other people's points of view on
what you're doing most of all your
parents second of all the other people
that are closest to you there is nobody
in this room that's gonna achieve
anything that they want if they're gonna
worry about somebody else's point of
view on what they want and how they're
going about doing it let me make this
very clear
life is very binary this is very
black-and-white if you were navigating
your life right now with the fear of
judgment of other human beings
regardless of who they are starting with
your mother and working all the way down
you are going to be limited in your
happiness comma what you achieve it's an
incredibly difficult thing to achieve I
don't say it lightly I don't think it's
so easy I'm just telling you how it is
and if you look at around and you look
at how its laid out it's a very powerful
thing so I think one thing that you have
to start understanding is is it true is
it you one of my biggest problems is I'm
42 years old I grew up in a world where
entrepreneurship and business was not on
a pedestal that it is today
I grew up in a time where education was
the only way out I grew up where getting
a good job was a significant win not the
word entrepreneur didn't even exist in
my adult in my adult life I can
myself a businessman not even the word
entrepreneur coming out of my mouth
until my late 30s mid 30s so my biggest
fear right now is if I could wish you
anything if I could wish every person at
this conference anything besides health
anything besides health the first thing
I would wish you is self-awareness do
you actually know yourself the biggest
problem is entrepreneurship went from
something that nobody cared about to
something that everybody now wants to be
when I look if you're under 25 years old
in the world right now you only want to
be two things an entrepreneur or an
influencer I mean I get period only two
things the problem is 97% of people
aren't good enough to do that it's hard
to do those things so to me the biggest
thing that I want to lay down before I
get into how you should do it and what
content you make and what you should do
and I'll get into that in a minute
before we get into those dynamics I'm
desperately interested in do you know
yourself
are you actually capable of doing that
business or that app or that startup or
that concept I think one of the things
that I spend a lot of time thinking
about is that the 19th employee at
Facebook made more money than the
founder of almost every other company
period and I just know that there's a
lot of people in here right now that
think they're gonna start the next
supreme or adidas or start the next
Instagram or Facebook or do this that
and the other thing and the reality is
that they would be a remarkable number
six a remarkable number 13 a remarkable
number 49 and that's very important to
me the same way something else is
unbelievably important to me which is
the following there's a lot of people
who want to build a business who are
sitting here who started building a
business but they don't realize that
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
and the business they have makes them
very happy but making two hundred
thousand dollars a year is going to make
them very unhappy and that Delta isn't
worth it
self-awareness my friends listen you
would be you would not think of me the
same way as a businessman if you
realized how much money I leave on the
table every year how much money I've
left on my career how much that is not
my KPI that is not what I strive for you
would think about me differently some
would think about me better some would
think about me worse left right that's
fine I don't really care to be honest I
care for you to understand that when you
understand yourself the greatest thing
that comes from it is you're happy you
also are far more likely to be
successful because one thing that people
don't talk enough about is how much hard
work it actually takes to succeed just
sheer time and effort I think one of the
great things about building a big
business is the process and yet right
now my great fear is that so many people
want the thing that you get from
building a successful company not the
process of building a successful company
we are in such a world now where all of
us through the content we put out on
whatever social network you use are
putting out such an extreme version of
our lives that people are becoming
envious of their friends everybody in
this room is now the PR agent of
themselves everybody's putting out the
best photo from their vacation ever
everybody's putting out the most
exciting night of their lives people are
actually now doing things in real life
just for the photo to put on [ __ ]
Instagram and this is very important to
understand because we as humans are
wired often to envy and be jealous and
curious and dwell on not being on that
boat and what that leads to is
short-term behavior everybody's looking
to make a quick dollar so that they can
go on that yacht or go to Ibiza or buy
that car or that bag or that sneaker and
this is
100% the poison that is in the system
and so for me I want to know why why do
you want to be successful for me I
didn't even really necessarily want to
be successful I just couldn't breathe if
I wasn't selling something or building a
business it's all I knew there was
nothing else it was why I was such a bad
student
I couldn't even appease the hour I
needed to be a decent student a day
because I needed every minute selling
baseball cards or wine or whatever I was
up to at that point in my life there was
no choice and so that's what I wish on
everybody else I wish that you wake up
every morning and have no choice that
what you do is how you breathe it's
become so extreme for me it makes me
feel selfish of how it impacts my family
or anything else because there's no
choice
it's how I breathe and so listen my
friends I can tell you a lot of things I
can tell you the following things in
Malaysia easily you should spend as much
money on Facebook ads as you possibly
can
I did the homework it's ridiculous
everybody here I don't care what you do
you should buy Facebook ads you should
make pictures and videos you should post
them as often as possible you should
look at what works and what doesn't and
keep doing it and you should do it a lot
with an if you have a dollar spend a
dollar if you have a million dollars
spend a million dollars if you want a
tactic to be successful whether you sell
popcorn or hats or you're a lawyer or
you have a TV show I don't care what you
do you should spend money on Facebook in
Malaysia because it's grossly
underpriced period if you came here for
a tactic like you want to write
something down to do with your business
here it is spend it's much [ __ ] money
on Facebook as you can
and now you can leave thank you for
coming if you came for a tactic and I'm
not kidding my career the reason I get
to stand up here I'm good at certain
things I'm bad at certain things the one
thing I've been great at professionally
is I've always executed in a place that
was underpriced at the time which helped
me grow people you know it's when when
you take a business that there's three
million dollars a year and has 10%
profit $300,000 before expenses you know
people had to get paid and you grow that
business from three to sixty million
dollars in seven years and you didn't
take any money from venture capital or
get a credit line from a bank or do
something else to do that you have to
make every penny act like a hundred
dollar bill that's what I did in 1996
that was having a website that was
having an email service and that was
having a email service a website and
most of all Google AdWords the reason I
come here and yell so much about
Facebook is because Google AdWords in
two thousand one two three four five or
so underpriced that when I was buying
AdWords for five ten cents a click they
were returning so much money that I was
able to grow there's been nothing since
2002 three four or five Google that
looks like Facebook today in that last
thirteen years that's why I come here
and yell about it so much because I know
it's a special moment in time and it's
gonna go away because just like Google
those prices go up and just like Google
in the beginning people click those ads
on Google more than they do today and
they were five cents now they're fifteen
dollars and people click them less right
now Facebook and Instagram ads in the
feed are under priced you're engaging
with it you're seeing it in five to
seven to nine years we might be on voice
devices we might be on VR we might be on
a are our attention is gonna move it may
be a new app that somebody in here does
create that takes the attend
[ __ ] it's just attention it's just
attention and once you have the
attention you have to know what to do
with it
that's how you convert I have the
attention of everybody right now if this
is a good keynote that will be good and
if it's not that will be bad it's not
very complicated just because you buy
Facebook ads how many people here have
bought Facebook ads and it didn't work
raise your hand raise it high it's good
everybody's like raise it high high I
know Asia doesn't like to show failures
go higher higher higher look at keep it
up I want everybody to look around
higher please higher I want everybody to
learn let's do it together you've run
Facebook Ads and it didn't work
raise your hands look around these
people suck I'm kidding but I'm not let
me explain what I mean by that is that
execution by these people sucked but it
doesn't mean it doesn't work right I
always talk about a piano and a
basketball a piano and a basketball for
me has made me no money but for Elton
John and LeBron James it's made them
billions of dollars the biggest problem
right now with marketing is people do
something it doesn't work and they think
it doesn't work without realizing they
didn't work so for me why I'm so
passionate is because what's amazing is
these products are under priced in
America but when you take them outside
of America they become even better
people in this room complain or cry or
debate or worry that there's only 30
million people without realizing that
that is normally the reason you have an
advantage to me the great thing about
being not in Silicon Valley in this era
of Technology eating up the world you're
able to see what's happening in mainland
China and in the US and you're able to
attack that here because humans are
humans yes there's different dynamics
but you're able to take tactics and
deploy them within market influencers
Instagram in this market are grossly
underpriced Facebook is grossly
underpriced podcast advertising here is
grossly underpriced content marketing on
LinkedIn if you're in the b2b business
here is grossly underpriced YouTube ads
here as pre-rolls are grossly
underpriced so for me pictures audio and
video and written words on these
platforms is what you should be doing
and I think sometimes people struggle
because they're looking for so many
different complicated things it's very
simple in 1984 in America MTV had all
the attention of all the kids and
Michael Jackson and Madonna understood
that and made as many videos as they
could for that and they became the
biggest stars in the world
it's not very complicated I mean the
whole world's elections are getting
twisted upside down because the world's
changed yet when it happened here
everyone's like holy [ __ ]
but why you're watching it happen
everywhere this has happened the biggest
problem that most people make right now
in 2018 today right the second is they
think it's coming yes this is coming
this is coming this has happened this
has happened and so for me as I as I
take the energy of the room as I look at
people who were hitting me up on the way
here as I'm looking at this market
there's a very difficult thing that I'm
struggling with because the answer is
both sides to what I'm about to say but
I'm gonna paint you a picture the
biggest concern and exciting thing for
me is actually the same thing and I
don't know you individually to know but
let me tell you what I mean by what I'm
setting up most people here will be
successful if they could be more patient
for longer yet most people will fail in
here if they're delusional and keep
doing the same thing for a long
time waiting for the thing to happen
it's one in the same the most difficult
question for me to answer is when should
you stop doing what you're doing because
I actually have to spend time with you
and really look under the hood to know
are you completely in outer space and
have a terrible idea and you stink and
of course we should change it or the
other thing that so many people struggle
with you're so impatient and you're so
caught up in short term metrics like how
many followers you have or how many
sales you made or how many leads did you
generate that you quit too soon because
nothing happens overnight it's one in
the same but that is what's happening
that is what's happening this paradigm
of that and then going back to where I
started the operating system here most
people are in a place where they're
coming from defense and they're letting
other voices dictate their actions so
many of you want to be successful to
prove to your parents that they were
wrong and you were right to do this
thing the problem with that is when you
want to prove a parent wrong how many
people here are doing what they're doing
because they love it but there's a part
of them that's doing it because they
want to prove somebody wrong raise your
hand raise it high I want to get a sense
so for all the hands up including myself
the vulnerability of that is you're so
hungry to prove to somebody that they're
wrong that you try to go too fast
because you can't wait to get to the
feeling of proving somebody wrong my
biggest thing is perspective do you have
perspective for example do you
understand how long you're gonna live
like obviously we don't know anything
can happen but most of this room is
probably gonna live for 50 to 70 years
or more yet none of you act like that
you're gonna live for 50 to 70 years
more
but you're trying to rush into something
and when I say I mean I sit across
people all the time that are 20 30 40 50
years old and I say oh I like this this
is gonna take seven or eight years and I
think you've really got something and
they're disappointed they're like you
could see their face like they think I'm
supercool they're super excited to get
ten minutes with me we look at it and I
say which is rare because I only say one
out of every 50 times this is gonna work
it's in seven or eight years I think you
got something and they're disappointed
and it runs through my head this is
we're living in a [ __ ] up world
this person's 27 years old I told her
she's gonna win in seven years and she
thinks that's a disaster because she
thinks 34 is old or that's too long or I
don't want to wait that long my friends
in America the top 1% financially make
the bottom the bottom of the top 1% to
get into the top 1% you have to make
four hundred forty thousand dollars a
year okay four hundred forty thousand a
year which is an enormous amount of
money yet in the way it's currently
structured people don't even think
anything's successful until a million
and yet only 1% ever get there
do you understand how rare it is to live
a life where you're fully in control and
don't work somewhere where you live your
life based on how much you earn and pay
all your bills and have all your fun
based on yourself that is super rare
that is super hard and to me the reason
I put entrepreneurship on a pedestal is
because if you can be a successful
entrepreneur you get to live your
professional life on your terms you get
to sleep in your bed it is let me tell
you one thing about entrepreneurship
that we don't talk enough about with
entrepreneurship if you own it if it's
yours everything is your fault you know
the best thing about working who works
for somebody raise your hand raise your
hand if you work somewhere you know what
the best part about working somewhere is
you get to blame somebody out
no matter what it's never your fault
they [ __ ] up right the worst part of
being an entrepreneur if it's yours is
everything's your fault
people like blaming other people but the
reality is it's your fault if it's
broken over there you employed that
person to do it that's your fault but
you're still in control and it is the
best feeling and so for me I'm just in a
place where does the person in this room
understand why they're doing it what do
they want I think we're in a place where
people's Northstar are confusing you
know it's very short-term and I'm just
trying to get people to buy into
different things for me if you actually
love the process of building if what
makes you happy is building it you will
win forever because you've already won
like I'm winning every day regardless of
the outcome because my love is my
process it's very powerful and and I I
wish I wish people spent more time with
people that are older and understood
what life is really about
I really do number two do you understand
how special right now is this internet
thing it's gonna be big and it's a lot
bigger than we realise it and for me the
fact that so many people here can get a
piece is very powerful we spend too much
time on WeChat
too much time on Facebook too much time
on uber we look up here the magic of the
Internet is the longtail the magic of
the Internet is the person who would
have worked somewhere that they were not
happy who now sells cake on Instagram
and makes seventy thousand a year doing
that and very happy versus making eighty
one thousand being a lawyer or sixty
seven thousand being an executive that
is the power of this right now
not that you're gonna build Instagram
not that you're gonna build Amazon or
Weibo that you can actually build a
business or something for yourself that
lets you do something you like versus
something you don't like do you know
what percentage of our time we spend at
work just enormous amount when you die
the amount of time you spend working is
right there with sleeping like you work
in sleep take up your life and so I
think it's a big deal because it's
practical it's math it takes up a lot of
your life and do you know that there's a
lot of people in this room who have a
passion but the reason they won't leave
their job right now is not because they
can't afford it but because they don't
want to take a step back to great take
three steps forward there are people in
this room who will live the next 45
years of their life unhappy because they
wanted two extra bedrooms in their house
that they will never use I'm being dead
serious
you so care what other people think of
you you're not willing to sell your home
and go live in a neighborhood that's not
as nice drive a car that's not as nice
to start a business that will make you
happy and so you will stay in a job for
another 21 years that you hate just to
pay for the facade of success of people
opinions that you value more than your
own happiness that [ __ ] with me like
you would not believe it blows my mind
that most of the world is willing to
live their life completely predicated on
the judgment of other people that is
scary and I look and you a lot of you
know me I was watching I don't want to
be motivational rah-rah I want to be a
little bit more detailed I don't want to
be like you can do yeah I don't want
the problem is the details are so simple
start a podcast run Facebook Ads
make content for every platform it's
super underpriced
go I like anybody here who's bought an
e-book or a course for over $500 to
teach them something about digital
marketing is not smart I know digital
marketing there's plenty of things I'm
comfortable with you buying a course for
you do it but if you're talking about
digital marketing it's very simple
written words pictures video audio put
it in LinkedIn Facebook Twitter
Instagram Google I mean it's that basic
that's fine that's not why you're not
winning and not doing what you want the
reason you're not winning and doing what
you want is somebody's opinion of you
matters more than your opinion of
yourself somebody's opinion of you
matters more to you than your opinion of
yourself it's very true
and I'm so desperate to figure out how
you know ease you know okay cool I'm up
here I'm on stage
we're inspired for a second you're
pumped you're like yeah [ __ ] it I'm
gonna call my dad and tell him [ __ ] you
you know the problem is usually between
right this moment and when you get home
to make that call it wears off right and
so people ask me you know why do I keep
talking why do I keep putting up blogs
why do I keep doing my podcast why do
you keep saying this you know some
people yell at me Gary you keep saying
the same things yes I believe in them
like what am I supposed to make up
something I don't believe in to talk
about yes I believe in it because I know
that for some of you you've watched
three years of my video content and
maybe this talk cuz we're in the same
room is the one maybe it's not maybe you
don't even know who I am and this is the
first time and then you go watch a
puppet start listening to my podcast and
19 months from now I'll say the same
[ __ ] I just said here but maybe because
of the night before and the weather and
because it was audio instead of video it
clicks because that's how this works
but I'm telling you right now it is a
mind game and I'm telling you right now
and I've been spending a lot of [ __ ]
time on this it's about a couple of core
things and let me tell you one of the
most important core things that's about
and this is a difficult subject matter
and I've never really talked about this
on stage this is something I've been
thinking a lot about and I'm gonna talk
a lot more about and I figured I bring
something cool here there's this premise
I have in my mind about fake
environments fake environments what it
really means is what happens when
somebody's entitled and the entitlement
goes so far that the persons living in a
manner that isn't predicated on what
they're actually contributing one of the
things that I've been spending an
enormous amount of time is what happens
with the reverse of [ __ ] you dad when
your parents are actually too good what
happens when your parents love you so
much that they think the right thing to
do is to subsidize some of your life by
paying for it what is that doing because
I'm watching that very carefully and I'm
using a very specific example in here
that is obviously not gonna be real to
everybody so I want you to think about
the premise more than the example I'm
using which is are you living in a fake
environment let me give you an example
of a fake environment when your idea of
a business can raise a million dollars
to start it that's a fake environment
we're living in startup world in the
last five to seven years
a ridiculous thing you're a kid you come
up with an idea and your business is
worth four million dollars to venture
capitalists that's a fake environment
that's why it will collapse
why does real estate always collapse
biggest fake environments happen when
people are making too much money for
just connecting people together because
a market is so hot it's a fake
environment cryptocurrency many of us
were gonna be trillionaires on the back
of a theory Emre fake environments are
very dangerous the number one thing that
I thank my parents for is not putting me
in a fake environment punishing me when
I got bad grades even though they knew I
would be successful right accountability
not buying me things or paying for my
house or my uber or my trainer or
whatever the [ __ ] once I got old enough
I'm out of the house here's for college
which I'm so grateful for which is much
more than most people yet and after that
the greatest thing that ever happened to
me
because when you're hungry and there is
no food you go and learn how to hunt
but when you were fed and you didn't
have to hunt for it you become a zoo
animal and I don't know if you know what
happens to zoo animals when once in a
while back in the day they used to say
well this is mean let's let the zoo
animal back into the wild
and then that animal would die in one
minute because it was in the cage in the
zoo everything was taken care of when
they went out there the other animals
killed them and so fake environments is
very very important to me and if you are
on the drug of a fake environment no
matter where it comes from I highly
recommend you pay close attention to it
this is why so many people struggle with
government what's the right government
right you know I was born in communism
sounds great on paper if you go go read
mark ism
go read it sounds great until you
realize it suppresses the human spirit
right it's why big companies always lose
in the end
because nobody's incentivized anymore
cuz they get bad find a way to make
yourself more hungry
I have kids walk in my room all the time
they're like I'm so hungry I'm so this
than that and I'm like well go work go
live with four friends in a studio
apartment to sleep on the floor be
hungry whoa you're not as hungry as you
think you are and so but by the way
that's okay I actually you know I think
a lot of people misunderstand me I
actually have nothing to say to most
people if you don't complain I have
nothing for you if you don't complain
I'm not interested in talking to you you
want my basic premise of a winning human
being is a person who doesn't complain
they are super content and happy with
what is going on in their lives that is
maybe more than self-awareness back to
help that's what I want for you but if
you complain or blame or don't think you
have what you deserve you need to shut
the [ __ ] up and realize it's your fault
it's your fault if anything you're
sitting in here right now and you're
upset about it's your fault
stop listening to your mom and dad stop
stop worrying about what other people
think and sell your car and take public
transportation and use that money to go
start your company people come in my
office and they complain that nobody's
giving them any money for their idea
Gary I can't raise any money I'm like
cuz you're not good at it either your
idea sucks or you're bad at explaining
your idea the market is the market is
the market Gary my music is so good but
nobody's listening to my soundcloud the
only person that's telling a person
who's got music on soundcloud that it's
good and nobody's listening to it is
that person's mother the market is the
market is the market the market is the
market is the market let me tell you the
best part about blaming yourself for
everything whether it's true or not it's
just a good idea I'm telling you you
know I'm putting out a lot of this
content and people get mad at me they're
like Gary easy for you to say rich white
guy [ __ ] there's this there's racism
they're sexist I'm like I understand I'm
like you're right
life is not fair the problem is now what
what are you gonna tweet that it's not
fair
to me mental strategies interesting
because I like doing things whether the
writer oh I blame myself for everything
does it make sense to me that I'm it's
my fault and everything I guess at this
point I've been doing it for so long you
know how that happens right I just fully
believe it
if I looked from the outside if I were
you and looked at it yeah you would say
that's not your fault that's not your
fault that's their fault
here's the good thing when you actually
think it's your fault you feel in
control do you know why you are so upset
and frustrated because you don't think
you're in control because you don't want
to be accountable accountability sucks
you know why people get uncomfortable
when I talk about parenting because
nobody wants to be accountable if their
kids not doing well that they did
something wrong it's the ultimate
devastating feeling you love your child
so much right it doesn't mean it's not
right to talk about we are living in a
very very special time my friends super
special time we are living in easily the
biggest shift in our world in a very
long time and almost all of it is right
here you've got to start figuring out
how to love yourself and I'm gonna tell
you right now because I see I'm over it
starts and I mean it [ __ ] starts with
not listening to anybody else ever again
and then because a lot of you are like
okay Gary that's fine but my own voice
tells me I suck I'm gonna help some of
you right now and I've done this only on
DM and it's like so I'm getting goose
bumps it's so scary when I use this line
with people what happens I've never done
this publicly as well when I tell you to
cut every other voice out but yourself a
lot of you say [ __ ] that's the worst
voice of all right I'm gonna tell you
something very important that you need
to hear and it's maybe the most
important thing you could ever hear and
I hope you hear it again and again and
again not just for me if your voice is
telling you that you
somebody put that voice in you your mom
or your dad or your grandmother or your
neighborhood or your environment whoever
or that terrible person that does
something terrible to you as a youngster
they put that voice in you you now think
that's your voice it is not so please do
me a huge favor please let this keynote
be the starting point because I'm gonna
make it very basic you have one life and
the most scary thing for me in the world
is the look of regret on somebody who's
over 80 years old the scariest thing in
the world to me in my bones that I feel
is when I meet somebody over 80 years
old and they have regret on their face
because time is really close to running
out and there's not a lot more they can
do when I look at this audience the far
majority under 60 you've got a fuckload
more time and here's the most
interesting part and this is just the
most fascinating thing about life
everything that happened yesterday back
everything that happened yesterday back
means nothing
the biggest reason companies go out of
business or lose market share is because
they're looking at the back and
respecting it too much
the biggest reason most humans in here
will not be happier tomorrow is you will
spend tomorrow talking about something
that happened four years ago seven years
ago your mom did this your your brother
stole this money that business you
thought of uber like all dumb [ __ ]
literally what happened yes by the way
why do you think I'm so hungry for all
the success the thing that he read when
I came out here that clearly I think my
mom wrote write all those accolades
that's what I love about life and
business if tomorrow I start making bad
decisions and I start doing bad things
it all goes away 40 years of doing 42
years of doing probably 36 years of
doing all the right things all go away
if tomorrow I start doing the wrong
things
my friends you with yourself you with
yourself you with yourself yesterday
means nothing you with yourself know who
you are
execute against that and the best part
is all of you know who you are a lot of
you to say I don't know myself ah you
don't want to be what you see but once
you accept that and get quiet and
realize the past means nothing then you
can start the process of winning in
whatever that means to you
legacy money fun I don't give a [ __ ]
that's how life actually works start
taking advantage of it and the fact that
we live during this time versus what
your grandparents live with means that
everything I just said is more real
faster bigger better that's the
punchline I wish you the best life ever
thank you so much
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]